hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday January 27 2020 what's going
on how how's it going how are you people
I hope you're having a good day despite
the [ __ ] horrible day that it was
yesterday I'll get into that later I'll
try to make you laugh first as opposed
to [ __ ] dwelling on that [ __ ]
horrific horrific horrific [ __ ] but I
brought it up how do I segue well I'm in
New York City right now
home of the the [ __ ] oh the greatest
[ __ ] slice of peachy ever [ __ ]
head according to people here and then
people in Chicago oh it's not it's not
big enough it's not deep enough you know
what I mean I just filled New York's
pizzas just like surface you know
Chicago pizza it just has so much more
depth to it I love when fat [ __ ] sit
there and argue about pizza
you know what I mean that's like a great
day and so that's another great thing
about living in a first world country
you can get into a fist fight over who
has a better slice of pizza for your fat
[ __ ] dead body they do use too many
[ __ ] each or we do you see just slice
and shut the [ __ ] up
just be happy you didn't have to walk
five miles for fresh water your tubs of
[ __ ] but having said that if you can
recommend some good pizza or freckles
here is all about it I'll go try and get
me some get me someone at gave me some
ID and [ __ ] page yeah yeah I just got
here I took the red-eye I do what I do a
lot when I go to the airport well I put
on my [ __ ] headphones and I listen to
some music and as I listen to the music
I start fantasizing that I'm the person
doing it you know and I just sort of
drift off into you know me shirtless
singing some rocks
you know nobody commenting on my
alabaster torso actually enjoying it
attracted to it on some level you know I
just disappear into my freckled fantasy
and then all of a sudden like wow
there's like nobody here in the terminal
and then I look and they're already on
Group three and I'm like ah [ __ ] I'm
Group one all the overhead compartment
space is gonna be God so I get on the
[ __ ] plane I flew I flew in it was an
old plane was a wide-body notice I said
that I didn't say fat I didn't try to I
didn't try to body shame this airplane
the old - 4 - 4 in the middle - on the
UH non the sides right and I get there
and of course the everything's all
[ __ ] taken up so I start doing my
indignant white guy said really I pay
for a first-class ticket I can't get
overhead but sir if he could just relax
9/11 why are you being hostile whatever
the [ __ ] they said I didn't flip out too
much I was like well you know I finally
figured out a way to do it right I had
to like stick it in diagonally and then
I try to jam my backpack up there
because there was no room for it
underneath the seat which I would have
done but there wasn't any room and I
finally get the thing [ __ ] closed and
in comes this guy who's sitting you know
next to me you know just an unfortunate
looking human being you know you ever
see somebody that's older and despite
the fact that they're older you don't
even give him a break you just looking
at him like this person was never
good-looking
this person was born a four-state of
four is still a four like the like aging
actually helped him you know what I mean
he just had those [ __ ] you know those
fish eyes like too far apart [ __ ]
sort of hanging down and it left
45-degree angle like he used to have a
fish head and then somebody [ __ ]
squeezed it into making it round he
shows you he's [ __ ]
got the receding hairline but he hasn't
shaved the head so he just you know he
looks like a character actor from a
1970s gritty [ __ ] movie you know when
you look who is that guy was in
everything what the [ __ ] his name
that's what he looked like right stupid
pants [ __ ] top of his ass crack hag
and I'm just ah this [ __ ] here
what does he do he comes head on a
[ __ ] swivel right and you know the
deal when you're on a plane if the
compartment is closed that means it's
full right I'm not gonna lie to you I
opened one in vain and once I saw it but
I closed the [ __ ] thing now mine
because my because I had to stick my bag
in an angle and also get my backpack up
there and of course that [ __ ] also put
his [ __ ] jacket up there you know it
was a lot of you know trying to stuff it
in there to get it closed I finally got
it closed what is old fishhead though he
[ __ ] reaches right up and he opens it
up and I'm just sitting there going he's
in my head I immediately said he's not
gonna [ __ ] be able to get it closed
he's not strong enough all right fish
people do not do push-ups he's not gonna
have the tricep [ __ ] strike that he's
gonna need to close this [ __ ] thing
and I sat there like the wise old bald
man that I am and I watched him make two
are the most pathetic attempts you
remember the first time you tried to do
a pull-up she'd never done one in your
life it's like those [ __ ] muscles
they're not even develop you don't you
don't ever use them you don't like so
you got a [ __ ] bar over your bed and
you pull yourself up in the morning you
never use those [ __ ] whatever muscles
those are remember the first time I
tried to do a pull-up it was like I
would think my back was paralyzed you
know you have to [ __ ] start out no
wiggling around like a [ __ ] goddamn
bug cutting a spider web you know
kicking your feet trying to get up and
over the bar so this [ __ ] guy right
he comes back down comes back down and
he sort of stares it and then looks
around I'm like yeah that's right fish
head you're not gonna [ __ ] try and
close that are you you're not right
does any moves so I do my big first
class exhale I go right
big time caddy if I had if I just
[ __ ] ever had long hair by had hair I
would have give him a big [ __ ] hair
flip okay I was going full [ __ ] chick
attitude on this one and then I got up
and it took me like three attempts and
it's tough that [ __ ] guy's stupid one
of those [ __ ] puffy coats everybody
haves they used to be huge when I was a
kid then they figured out this new
technology so now they're really small
its everybody threw out the big ones
remember the big ones and the feathers
were all settled down below
you [ __ ] waist and balls would be
sweating but your shoulders you have
frostbite remember that [ __ ] North Face
his little [ __ ] North Face Oh Fish
Face didn't tuck back in the [ __ ]
North Face so now I got to push the I
finally get it all tucked back in and I
sit down you know comes walking in now
some old guy you can't get mad at old
people they're all he's gonna be dead
soon right so he [ __ ] comes in he
reaches up he opens it now I feel bad
you're not gonna get so he [ __ ] it does
it and think oh Jesus Christ I get back
up again I trying to get it closed tuck
in the [ __ ] jacket back in like fine
muttering to myself I'm gonna [ __ ] it up
to do listen I'm on [ __ ] [ __ ]
time pay for a [ __ ] ticket right in
the [ __ ] clothes the thing that didn't
realize the old guy was right behind
when he goes he goes oh thanks a lot but
I just go yeah don't worry I don't have
to go to the gym now huh you know try to
play it off like I wasn't a [ __ ] angry
red [ __ ] but I am but I am so that was
me pushing my bag by the way it wasn't
me [ __ ] you guys always saying any
sound on this is me [ __ ] just like I
just sit here passing gas all the time
listen that was okay it was a bag
[ __ ] moving it's funny but now I'm
here in here in New York and why I might
as well talk about it it was [ __ ]
terrible day yesterday man for everybody
obviously
[Music]
un-fuckin'-believable
on phone I don't even know what to say I
cannot believe Kobe Bryant is gone man
and he with this beautiful daughter to
who I didn't know anything about like
most people Gianna Bryan I was reading
all this stuff about how you know she
was playing hoop and he was coaching her
and she wanted to go to Connecticut that
great program and then go to the WNBA
and I was just thinking about how the
WNBA the problem with it is they haven't
had their bill Russell's or
Chamberlain's Oscar Robinson Kareem burb
Magic Jordan taco fall right they
haven't had because nobody's watching it
right I do a bit about this on my
Madison Square Garden album that's
coming out I finally finished editing
that thing how all these [ __ ]
feminists out there yeah and then the
dead [ __ ] moaning and [ __ ]
complaining [ __ ] broads man I'm
telling you all they do is [ __ ] moan
and complain
did you and they complain about [ __ ]
guys they're number one [ __ ] problem
is is they don't support each other you
got a whole [ __ ] standing there on
the [ __ ] sidelines of a football game
freezing your [ __ ] ass off talking
about guys you know running after angry
coaches that are down by 20 at halftime
where the [ __ ] away why don't you go to
the WNBA huh cuz they don't they want to
show up when it's done after a bunch of
guys died building the [ __ ] bridge
and then they want to name it have to
fund some chick or didn't shave her
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's oh that's that's feminine that
famine is a right guy I'm just saying I
don't understand why they don't support
it you know if you're really all about
broads why don't you go watch and play
hoop and start selling out arena 3 is
with a bunch of [ __ ] women screaming
watching women play basketball and then
they'll get the NBA contracts if you
just would show up that
that's not how they work they want to go
in and ruin a guy's a bunch of guys
sitting around watching a game having a
good day you have to be sensitive now
that I'm here why don't you [ __ ] off and
watch the W win where is this going bill
this is supposed to be some sort of
tribute um anyways just I don't know I'm
just trying to be extra stupid and funny
today just because it's just so it's
just so [ __ ] brutal and sympathy's
out to the help I say then the IDS of
like names I'm gonna [ __ ] these up the
Altobelli family John Kerry and ELISA
and they have like a sister now they
have a son and another son and a
daughter and those two poor kids lost a
sister their mother and their father man
it's just [ __ ] brutal Sarah and
Payton Chester and then Kobe's sistent
coach Christina Mauser and then the
pilot arizo Bayon I hope I said that
right man just condolences to anybody
who knew them it's just [ __ ] brutal I
got to tell you as a Celtics fan
I can't believe Kobe's gone because I
was it's just
Kobe just won he always wins
and I think like a lot of people just
seeing somebody like that get taken you
dislike yeah that really can just happen
to anybody at any time man shoutout to
the BBC I hope you guys are doing all
right you know I don't know how you
shake that one off I really do not know
how you don't know what Kobe Bryant
looks like and you show LeBron James
footage they actually I started to watch
the clip it was so [ __ ] embarrassing
they show Kobe Bryant with his daughter
Gianna in every picture like the two of
them I mean I gotta tell you those
pictures is my goal with my daughter and
she was smiling like that
anybody can make a three-year-old if
yours a three-year-olds father she's
gonna have an ear-to-ear grin when you
show up but when they're 13 and they're
still smiling like that you're a hell of
a father so
I hope I pull that off at some point but
so they had this amazing picture of Kobe
and is his lovely daughter and you know
they have 1978 to 2020 and then as
they're talking about the tragedy and
Kobe Bryant and everything he did in the
NBA they was showing footage of LeBron
James and I'm not exaggerating
LeBron literally turns around you
clearly see on the back of his jersey it
says James
they literally a sum of fact they look
nothing alike he has his name on the
back they did wear the same jersey I
mean I could see could I can't even see
confusing Peyton in Eli Manning well I
guess maybe he played for the Colts they
had blue and white and Giants or blue
and grey but like Peyton has a longer
rectangle shaped head like his head is
shaped like the back what's that big
stupid Mercedes truck that dumb it looks
like a [ __ ] toaster why the [ __ ] am I
making fun of Peyton Hank Manny's head
because tragedy I don't know how to I
don't know how to weave my way through
this it's just it's just [ __ ] yeah
how do you get past this one so then of
course you know I get a bunch of [ __ ]
emails and [ __ ] you know as you do when
you [ __ ] fly you know no one no one
ever text you when you just [ __ ] they
see a helicopter flying over or a plane
having a good time it's always like you
know when something bad happens and then
they go dude don't [ __ ] do that
anymore you know I would love to find
these people and every time somebody
dies in a car accident which is like
every [ __ ] 10 seconds to tell you not
to drive a [ __ ] car anymore I can't
tell you this is if you don't do it then
you'll never understand how [ __ ]
ridiculously safe it is I mean every
there's like a [ __ ] zillion flights I
don't know millions of people fly every
[ __ ] day and nothing happens every
spoken to every [ __ ] day millions of
people drive and a bunch of [ __ ] happens
and then people go what people drive it
and that's not necessarily true if you
if you if you take in commercial
aviation there's way more people [ __ ]
flying than you believe and this is what
I my thing is is everybody I nobody I
know has been in a [ __ ] plane crash
alive or dead everybody I know has been
in a [ __ ] car accident alright two
different different degrees I've had
people die in them I've had people
[ __ ] now they have limps I've had
people [ __ ] collapse lungs and all
that type of [ __ ] and everything so I
appreciate all your guys concerns you
know and now there's gonna be a bunch of
helicopter experts who don't know the
first [ __ ] thing about a helicopter
about how it works and all of that [ __ ]
and they're gonna say a bunch of [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] and you just you just don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
so I'll just leave it at that
[Music]
alright every [ __ ] thing I just like
you know I mean it's every time somebody
has a [ __ ] heart attack would you
like if somebody came up to you you
should stop eating that anybody each
safe each safe maybe let's let's stick
with the main thing here okay it's a
unbelievable tragedy like I haven't seen
it ELISA reminds me when like princess
died died in that car crash as far as
like a global [ __ ] and like I live like
Marc Marquez MotoGP champion motorcycle
racer from Spain he even put something
on Instagram about it the effect that
this guy had on people so the [ __ ]
[ __ ] brutal that's all we could say
and this is why I didn't want to talk
about it and why don't we just continue
with the morbid [ __ ] I'm going to be
doing the Patrice O'Neal benefit the one
of the greatest friends I ever had my
life who passed away in 2011 and this is
the ninth annual
so Neil comedy benefit something
positive we have an amazing line-up all
right what do we got here we have Ronny
Chang who had one of the best specials
of last year I don't know how the [ __ ]
he didn't get nominated for a Grammy you
know I don't get it
Judy gold one of my favorite comedians
amarelle one of my favorite
up-and-coming Andrew Schultz another
great up-and-coming cipher sounds gonna
be DJs DJing the pride at Trenton New
Jersey Paul virzi the perennial host
rich vos the [ __ ] Billy Crystal of
this benefit always coming and always
crushing it as a host we got Roy Wood
jr. from this is not happening just one
of the best comics I know and then we
got a couple of popping guests some big
names there you know I don't know
they'll pop and guess one's a definite
one's a [ __ ] baby we shall see what's
happened I think this is like the best
lineup we have it's gonna be a lot of
fun as always and thank you thank you
thank you thank you to everybody who is
once again helped us sell this event out
to help raise money for Patrice's mom
and his loved ones and it's just been a
great thing and thank you too Maureen
Tarin who as always you know did all the
work behind the scenes and dealt with
all of us crazy comedians and thank you
to the stand who every year has done you
know wonderful things supporting the
benefit you know I can't believe it's
been nine years already Jesus Christ but
this is gonna be a good one
this right here not that the other ones
weren't good ones but this one's going
to be a [ __ ] I think this is going to
be a great one so Oh Billy freckles went
out to the comedy store the other night
and I did the belly room first then I
did the main room and then I did the o.r
the original room and just had
that's a great [ __ ] time just a great
[ __ ] time I was one of those nights
were each crowd was it was was just on
fire tried out a bunch of [ __ ] I had to
make sure with this lineup that I was
gonna be on my game so you know I don't
know anyway just too much [ __ ] I hate
doing [ __ ] comedy on days like this I
really do
well-built fortunately you're not that
funny so just you know we'll just turn
it into a giant [ __ ] monologue how
about that wait did I put the live
Reed's here I'm leaving trying to copy
and paste as I'm doing this oh by the
way thank you to everybody who enjoyed
the Don Gavin podcast Don was is is
somebody who that I learned so much from
and when I was coming up in Boston and
just one of the funniest bastards ever
and I didn't realize I hated that I
didn't get into it until the end of the
interview but speaking of the NBA in a
positive way Don Gavin was [ __ ] there
at basically the the inception I have to
talk to him more about this I want to
get him back on my podcast to talk about
the people that he saw he used to go to
the Boston Garden I read that book I
mentioned earlier this year I read that
book about Bill Russell and Bob Cousy
and it's as much as it's about them and
all the racial horrific stuff that Bill
Russell had to go through it's also
subtly a history of the NBA from the
beginning right up until you know the
end of kuzey and bill Russell's careers
and when Don Gavin was going in the late
1950s I loved that I read the book I was
just like so there was like nobody there
he goes I got ya he goes I watched the
Celtics win the NBA championship in like
57 or 58 and for like a half-filled
Boston Garden
imagine that we used to go to like
almost every single game so he probably
saw him play the Minneapolis Lake I
didn't even ask him about the different
franchises he saw probably saw George
Mikan all of these guys a young Wilt a
young Bill
so all of that he was at the Bob Cousy
retirement ceremony with that guy in the
upper deck famously loved we loved and
he was also there at the inception of
the the great second-to-none as far as
I'm concerned Boston comedy scene that
started at the ding ho he was there and
it was amazing I had one of my favorite
comics of all time sitting across from
me and I just wish I'd got more into
it's towards the end of the interview
that he starts talking about you know I
started talking to him about first
concerts he went to and [ __ ] like that
yeah so it's a I'd like to think it's a
good interview sorry if I'm a little
[ __ ] jet-lagged here I [ __ ] took
the red-eye back I got like five hours
sleep it [ __ ] shed guy when my Bose
headsets [ __ ] wore out I finally took
him off I want to sleep on my side so I
had to take off they had said and I'm
[ __ ] rolling over I just hear that
guy snoring and I just muttered yeah of
course he [ __ ] snores too goddamned
fish-headed [ __ ] with his
[ __ ] no arms and his [ __ ] snore
and goddamn [ __ ] nose doesn't take a
lot doesn't take a lot you think with
all the tragedy bill you'd put things
into perspective now still getting mad
at some fishhead guy that [ __ ] it makes
me close my goddamn luggage compartment
again as I get across this country in
four hours and 55 minutes upset about
something
I had a [ __ ] one of those seat beds
still complained still [ __ ]
complained all right you know why cuz
I'm an American alright butcher box
everybody okay the game is just around
the corner which means lots of good
times with friends and lots of food
whether you're cooking for a crowd
tough crowd way of cooking for a crowd
or just getting together with the fam
snacking is half the fun
talk about your go-to snacks to make for
a party what are some crowd favorites
I like to put some kale chips out for
the vegan people in the room and then I
like try to like you know sort of push
my plant-based diet on everyone in the
room I like to have the game on at like
a low volume so people can't really hear
it because I think the conversations are
more important what am i go to snacks I
don't know I I don't [ __ ] know I I
make some burgers that's what I do right
make burgers do I have go to snacks
I don't know what I do why do they put
me on the spots like I [ __ ] love the
meat that you sent me I don't want to do
it alright whether you're going to be
watching the big game or not here's a
reason to throw a party I like how
they're not saying with the big game is
this is very good they're covering all
their bases here butcher Fox is offering
free wings for life when you sign up now
whether you love football I just love
any excuse to eat a plate of wings now's
your chance
sign up for butcher bucks and snack like
it's game day all year round free wings
for life when you sign up now I had to
say that again personal experience with
butcher bucks it's just it's
high-quality meat delivered right to
your door I absolutely love the Heritage
bread pork my favorite pork chop I've
ever made at home I ate that thing I
thought about it for three days that's
how good it was alright every month
butcher bucks ships a curated selection
of high-quality meat right to my home
all meat is free of antibiotics that
added hormones each box has 9 to 11
pounds of meat enough for 24 individual
meals or for fat [ __ ] to finish in one
sitting I can customize my box or go
with one of theirs either way I get
exactly what I want
butcher box is a no-brainer options like
a 100% grass-fed grass-finished beef
free organic chicken heritage pork used
to be bread now it's just heritage for
wild caught Alaskan salmon you know
coming to Saturday that wild Alaskan
I'm gonna go run wild and sugared
nitrate-free bacon with butcher box you
get the highest quality meat around for
just six dollars a meal and they even
have free shipping nationwide nationwide
except for Alaska and Hawaii because
they don't need it right Alaska you're
shooting your own [ __ ] meat in Hawaii
yeah you got those pineapple trees there
right you're out there surfing catching
some koi right now you can get free
wings for life free wings for life
Plus $20 off your first bucks that's
three pounds of wings in every box for
the life of your subscription and if you
only need a pound a half of every month
you know everybody else is gonna be
screaming during the apocalypse you can
be sitting there eating [ __ ]
barbecued chicken wings laughing your
ass off and when you're done with them
you can throw the bones at the zombies
Plus $20 off your first first bucks just
go to butcher bucks comm slash burn or
use promo code burn check out that's
butcher bucks comm slash burn or use
promo code burr at checkout all right oh
my god this company's called brave this
must be about I don't know some female
comic who talked about some part of her
vagina no sorry alright brave everybody
you are living in the surveillance
economy what is that you might ask every
time you download a webpage you are not
just downloading the content text and
images you are also downloading privacy
invading trackers many popular media out
sites sorry before hours sleep last
night many popular media sites have over
100 trackers on every page you are being
profiled and tracked across the web so
what you might say your digital profile
includes informations about you such as
your search and watch history your
personal beliefs or your location every
way you've been and even your current
GPS coordinates these digital profiles
allow companies to head to have you have
never heard of to maintain intimate
profiles about you and everyone you know
data collected about you can be used to
manipulate both you and
xiety at large but there's way but
there's a way to protect yourself and
remove the surveillance economy start
using brave brave stops data grabbing
trackers and creepy ads from following
you across the web which allows you to
browse up to six times faster than with
the other browsers whose kitten who
that's the big selling point all right
you can get to your porn six times
faster without anybody seeing you do it
here's an important fact about us brave
isn't anti Ed's brave is anti tracking
brave users can choose to opt in to
brave Ed's a privacy respecting ad
network run by brave brave never sees
your personal data or behavior let alone
sells that information for profit and
you'll never see an ad from brave unless
you explicitly choose to participate
with brave ads you can earn you can earn
rewards Jesus bill with brave ads you
can earn rewards for any ads you choose
to view that's right out-of-the-box
brave will block ads and trackers but
you can choose whether you want to see
the ads how often they appear and get
rewarded for your attention if you click
on one how does brave make money if you
choose to opt in to brave ads brave
takes a cut of the advertising spend
what a cut of the advertising spend
whenever you choose to view an ad
there's a typo in there some way that's
how brave earns money and keeps the
browser free it takes less than 60
seconds to switch to brave import your
bookmark with the one click and start
enjoying a better internet listeners of
the mmm podcast can easily switch to
brave today go to brave com / / dovo
brave today
that's brave dot-com / / and switched
today alright Jesus Christ the reeds
the reeds the reeds are on fire no they
weren't [ __ ] goddamn yon and my way
through that [ __ ] all of a sudden
the tiredness of being on a [ __ ] on a
red-eye flight but I had to do it you
know why cuz I had to put my lovely
daughter to bed before I [ __ ] before I
went on the plane man she's alright so I
got her doing this thing right where I
every every year for a birthday I make
her a homemade chocolate now I make a
yellow cake with chocolate frosting
right so I got it I would sit there and
be like who made you cake and she'd be
like dad and I'd be like why it should
be like uh because he's hunky I'm like
Dom not because I'm angry I made it
because I love you right I kept saying
that so now she says that I go who makes
the who made the cake and she's like dad
dad and I go why she goes because he
because you love me I go that's right so
now I do it for everything why dad dad
put you on your shoulder because you
love me cuz that's been my big thing you
know when you have a kid one of the
hardest things is before they can
comprehend the English language the
frustrating thing is you can't
communicate to them how much you love
them and it drives you it drives me up
the [ __ ] wall
and now she's starting to get it I hope
anyways I'm probably gonna drive her
nuts with it you know you know what
somebody agrees with you no you mean you
agree with somebody you understand how
much I love you yeah I get it
anyways tugger this buddy of mine he's
one of these guys he just doesn't
[ __ ] listen he's driving me nuts he
was asking me about something that he
had no idea about you know it was
something [ __ ] up that happened so I
was trying to explain it to him in the
entire time I'm explaining to him he's
gone huh yeah yeah yeah like [ __ ] I
mean what are you doing because what it
is is he one of the information and then
I could already hear the [ __ ] wheels
spinning on how he was gonna just
[ __ ] take what I just said and they
just go walk off and talk about it I
don't know the older I get the more
[ __ ] up I realized I am and the more I
realize how [ __ ] up
I am the more I can I see it in other
people and I don't know I want to say
it's making me judge people less because
I've seen how [ __ ] up I am and how
complex a human being is and that the
how they're not just this thing or that
thing but I was still upset with that
fishhead guy even though I was 100% my
fault that that I am [ __ ] you know I
had my headphones off and I said to
myself I said bill make sure you don't
have your headphones on a half hour
before and you know what those sneaky
bastards they state they loaded started
boarding the plane forty forty-five
minutes earlier so it wasn't fish-heads
fault I mean if it was his fault your
[ __ ] fish head isn't that enough
isn't that enough bill isn't that enough
for you by the way the second half of
the bill Bert podcast which has been
doing I want to say really well will be
released on Wednesday of this week and
we just we just did another one and old
Billy freckles has been off this for two
weeks that's it that's all I need two
weeks and now I look at them and I just
got I don't want to [ __ ] do that I
don't want to do it anymore so somebody
who can somebody who's out there who
knows about addiction can you explain my
level alright because I'm one of those
people that you would be like you are
addicted to nicotine right but then it
should have been hard for me to quit how
come I can just go like you know what
I'm not [ __ ] doing that anymore and
it's hard for three days and then two
weeks later I'm like yeah I'm never
doing that again why is it like I was
actually thinking today when I got out
of I got out of the [ __ ] taxi from
the airport and I was thinking how
little sleep I got and I was like well
thank God I didn't drink you know
and I really would have been feeling
like [ __ ] but uh just the thought I even
going out and having a drink now it's
like I think I just I I passed that
[ __ ] point I've even given a [ __ ]
about it I was just like you know I'm
never doing that again
why would I do that I actually really
enjoy watching people get shit-faced
though like I can totally be around it
and I enjoy watching people get
shit-faced
not because I'm judging them or laughing
at them I'm relating to it it's like so
that's what I looked like
there our phone call is gonna be neat
need to be made sometime around 11:50
7:00 a.m. the next day when you finally
get those greasy eggs in yourself
[ __ ] colleague Alcala Jesus I said I
I know you know it's kind of open you
were gonna pick up I don't really
remember what I said which is always a
lie but I do remember that you seemed we
I feel like we had some sort of
disagreement you know exactly that he
had a disagreement I hope there's not
any weirdness if I did anything to make
you uncomfortable or if I said my true
feelings about some things I'm sorry
that's [ __ ] I don't miss that at all
and I don't miss smokin cigars it's
[ __ ] weird when I was smoking him
that the thought of never doing it again
I was just like yeah it's gonna be
[ __ ] brutal nine outdoor day it's
great I love it no problem so now what
do I do
huh you know I can't fight you don't
drink I don't smoke cigars you know I
don't know about this [ __ ]
helicopters [ __ ] now you know people
all my friends everybody's you guys stop
doing you gotta stop doing it so if I
stop doing that what the [ __ ] do I do
that what a what do I do people if I'm
not killing myself or attempting to kill
myself how do I fill the day that is my
question you know what I'm gonna look up
right now I'm gonna look up sober life
activities sober life activities alright
alright now I got my eyes shut I'm not
looking I'm gonna let's I'm gonna try to
guess they probably have will have 10
I'm gonna try to guess some join a
sports league take up a hobby get into
cooking take a cooking class join a gym
go on walks watch some live music take a
vacation whatever they say alright
substance abuse meant three funds 30 99
things to do when you're sober
throw a sober dinner party oh yeah I
gotta tell all you users out there man
this is the fun you're missing throw it
sober dinner party invite your closest
friends over for dinner and dessert
substitute alcoholic beverages for
delicious and refreshing fruit infused
cocktails pick a playlist with piano or
classic tones to keep the vibe classy
and elegant
check out Spotify has already made
playlists according to the mood or genre
alright [ __ ] that rejuvenating spa day
at home solo or with friends invite a
few girlfriends over for herbal tea
I like this couple chicks over I got a
massage out of this what's going on here
is this for women only watch movies and
give each other
manicure
and pedicures don't forget the face mask
and hair conditioning treatments too
this is a fun way to pamper yourself and
help improve your parents at the same
time okay all right number three guys
night out slash girls night out plan a
weekend to go camping fishing or to a
sporting event in town I would go
camping or fishing I wouldn't go to a
sporting event and you watch everybody
else getting shit-faced having a good
time exercise run box do yoga huh okay I
got this one here we go hot yoga hike
swim anything just get out there stretch
it out
break a sweat exclamation yeah [ __ ] this
go for a drive bubble baths not just for
women hey Bill you don't drink half a
bottle of bourbon anymore what are you
doing said is there anything more boring
than taking a [ __ ] bath jesus [ __ ]
christ and he just sitting there in your
own filth in that [ __ ] dirty water
and it's just so goddamn hot I always
feel like you know this must be what
it's like you know the first five
minutes you know if you accidentally
encountered a tribe of cannibals and at
least Stuckey in the pot like at first
it's like bath water oh this is nice
they're so friendly play a game of golf
owner what is good side dishes is for
eating a human being
play a game of golf or practice your
swing at the driving range oh my god go
for a drive meditate read a book go see
a movie volunteer your time and services
that's probably the most productive one
to get yourself out of your own [ __ ]
head play basketball yeah great go blow
out your [ __ ] Achilles go swimming go
for a walk and and smile at every person
you pass by oh great hey how are you
sober psycho right in your journal
a new playlist for yourself or as a gift
for someone else oh my god this is just
showing this is showing why people get
[ __ ] up plan a garden organized and
clean out your closet and donate at
least ten items this thing's all over
the map are you trying to make me not be
a hoarder or all right [ __ ] this thing
this person claims 99 things to do sober
clip your toenails see if you can get it
in all one piece no sorry go to local
cinema subscribe to TV streaming service
watch to your heart's content watch all
the Golden Globes and Oscar nominees for
Best Picture revisit all seasons of Game
of Thrones before the final season watch
all ten seasons of Friends oh my god why
would you do any of this to yourself put
on a movie marathon buy a crossword
puzzle book learn ballet or tap-dancing
I would learn tap-dancing because I just
think would be [ __ ] hilarious if in
secret you became really great at
tap-dancing and then when you just
busted it out you know put on Yankee
Doodle Danny that did that did then you
do the big windmill
people like what in the [ __ ] is going on
and you just have this crazy smile on
your face
go ballroom dancing watch Cirque de
Soleil go to a theme park like
Disneyland dress up and attend the Opera
attend an art exhibit listen to songs of
all your favorite singers in one night
better than getting boozed man sing in a
karaoke place in front of a lot of
people playing board games
I'm gonna start crying go on an alcohol
free food trip relax in a bubble bath
have breakfast in bed
update your fashion sense read celebrity
websites and keep up with the
Kardashians this is all why people drink
this is really pathetic
run around the neighborhood and really
nice running shoes oh yeah this is so
much better than heroin sign up for a
gym membership try out trendy workouts
like CrossFit or underwater aerobics I
swear to god this isn't a joke go
bowling go bowling my god that's ten
lanes of [ __ ] booze bags alright
here's one that does last one to read
this one's throwing down 20 sober
activities that are more fun than using
drugs or drinking these [ __ ] [ __ ]
say bubble bath do you like team sports
there are leagues for bowling softball
touch flag football soccer hockey Oh
playing hockey could be fun start
reading
oh yeah that's way better than [ __ ]
you know taking DMT and seeing what the
other universe looks like sit down and
read [ __ ] George and them [ __ ] man
with the yellow hat visit a hobby or
craft shop join a gym take classes at
your local YMCA start an online course
start an offline that is to say it
happens in the real world course find
public gardens in your area visit a zoo
or an aquarium oh yeah nothing makes me
[ __ ] forget about booze like an
imprisoned animal volunteer that's a
good one learned how to write songs
alright okay you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna finish this podcast and I'm
gonna go right to a goddamn liquor store
wow that was a big [ __ ] swing and a
Miss the the read the reality is I don't
want to say what I'm going to say cuz
it's too goddamn negative about sobriety
alright I'm sorry I apologize for all of
that [ __ ] I'll tell you what's great
about being sober is waking up having
not drank that's [ __ ] great
and I'm not gonna lie to you it is
[ __ ] great till about 4:00 4:30 in
the afternoon and then it sucks until
you go to sleep alright that's the
truest [ __ ] I can tell you about it okay
good luck
and they're hearing enough bubble baths
in the [ __ ] world and Spotify
playlists and [ __ ] fruity sober
[ __ ] drinks that you can drink that
can make up for that all right dog Gavin
hey bill thanks for turning us on to Don
Gavin I was unfamiliar with him but I
listened to him live with the Manhattan
well that's his that's his new album a
reissued album on Spotify live with a
Manhattan and laugh more than I have in
a long time the man is hilarious hope
he'll be touring or releasing more
recordings in the future that's awesome
he is just [ __ ] hilarious and if you
notice he went out to LA he did Rogen's
podcast he did Marc Maron's podcast he
did my podcast all of us did stand-up in
Boston and all of us know that he is one
of the greatest of all [ __ ] time so
check it out dawn Gavin live with the
man with a Manhattan all right the bill
Bert podcast hey Billy airwaves thank
you for the bill Bert podcast awesome
that you're finally doing a video
podcast too
I love seeing how you guys sit in front
of what appears to be a display at
Dick's Sporting Goods flagship store
can't wait for more yeah that's sort of
our baked in advertising trying to get
people to get out there and see the
America that people think is is lost I
just did another one another episode of
his that of our show I should say that
uh shall be released in February all
right girl that lost virginity and yoga
class from last week no I thought you
saying she lost her virginity in a yoga
class I was like hey what pose is that
okay dear Billy never been kissed BRR
that's sad
all right last week some girl wrote to
you about how she was upset because she
gave a guy in yoga class some [ __ ] and
then that guy dropped her out of dropped
out of the class and out of her life you
told her to move on and stop obsessing
about the guy which is good advice if
the man promised to be in a relationship
ship with her if they had sex than I
agree what he did would make him an
[ __ ] however my advice of this girl
and all women out there is stop using
sex to get into a relationship whoo
there you go
[ __ ] isn't special to men like you
think it is it's important but not
special listen I know you guys aren't
gonna like the way this guy's saying it
but he is telling he's he's living his
truth right now a lot of women make men
wait for [ __ ] like this girl did for
seven months and hold it in front of
their heads like a carrot on a stick in
order to lure them into relationships
the only reason you should have sex with
someone is because you want to have sex
with them not because you hope to get
something out of that person oh my god
I believe the kids call these truth
bombs if you have sex and there is
chemistry there and a relationship
develops then great if it doesn't it
doesn't but using the vague promise of
[ __ ] to entice a man into a
relationship is shady practice it's like
a car dealer trying to sell you a car
without letting you take it for a test
drive first got a little sideways yeah I
know what you say anyway losing her
virginity virginity doesn't make her any
less of a person nothing was actually
lost and like you said she'll eventually
find the right person if she keeps
putting yourself out there to meet
people
I just want women to have some
perspective on where men are coming from
so they don't end up bitter and confused
like this girl thanks for the podcast
sorry you went a little hard there in
the end but I get what you saying that's
true it's true it's a big [ __ ] shell
game three-card Monte with one vagina
ain't gonna work yeah yeah there was a
lot of that there's a lot of that out
there god damn it good luck fellas
good luck single people good luck with
all of that [ __ ] those days are behind
me I can't argue with any of that you
know I don't leave if it's a car deal
it's like a car deal trying to sell you
a car without letting you take a
test-drive first that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz what like your heart relationships
going to be based on [ __ ] her
though I got to admit you know you could
make the chicky your dreams if she can't
kiss how long is that gonna last you
know and there's a lot of [ __ ] stuff
out there about how an MN are in bed and
then this is sort of this assumption
that women are just naturally sensual
and are good in bed and that is not the
case
all right ladies okay you're not all
[ __ ] you know I don't warm and open
it's a lot of [ __ ] shutdown lunatics
out there all right
fat friend hey Billy ballbuster I love
your podcast in your comedy thank you
you're one of the greatest of our time
in my opinion all right well you're
obviously not looking around but I'll
take that I'll take it all right so I
have a friend who happens to be pretty
[ __ ] fat and he's also a big fan of
you so I was thinking that maybe you
could give him some tough love and
convince him to start living a healthier
life one time he had 210 piece nuggets
with three sprites and two large fries
in one sitting and surprise surprise he
felt like hot garbage in the morning so
as a friend who cares for him but also
doesn't know how to approach telling him
how to improve his health I think he
needs someone to give him the honest
truth now oh sorry the honest truth
about how unhealthy it is to be as fat
as he is he is a great dude and all but
I don't want him dying of a heart attack
before he's even 21
thanks so much and as always go [ __ ]
yourself and have a great day um I don't
do just by the way you wrote this and
how funny this is I think that you can
handle this you know all right next
question I'm kidding you imagine if I
just started tapping out like that I
can't do that you know what you know I
can't do you know why I can't do you
what
[Music]
and I'm helping out the fatty for
somebody else all right what did I say
to the guy I'd just be like listen you
know we're great friends right
hey no rule is he's [ __ ] eating a
[ __ ] ham hock I just tell him like
listen man I'm worried about you
you got to start working out all right
I'm too tired to say this the right way
so just figure out the right way to say
this no one wants to see you [ __ ] fat
tits no chicks gonna want to blow you if
she's [ __ ] gotta you know sit there
trying to [ __ ] move your stomach
around to make sure it doesn't shift
down over your junk when you're laying
on your back okay I don't know how else
to put it
all right you should have your stomach
lanced like a [ __ ] I don't know
medieval boil yeah you can't blow out
your body before you're even 21 you
can't [ __ ] do it what are you doing
just straighten your [ __ ] body like a
rental car it's like how long how long
do you plan to live yeah he's setting
himself up for a horrible horrible
horrible like no quality of life all
right and you know you're gonna have to
spend your life with somebody at least
get with somebody you want to look at
you know what I mean if you're walking
around just you [ __ ] gigantic you
know it's limiting who you could [ __ ]
go out with unless you got a ton of
money then you can find some [ __ ]
skinny [ __ ] that she's just [ __ ] you
and getting you excited cuz she's hoping
you're gonna have the big one like Fred
Sanford and she can get your [ __ ]
house all right there's no reason to be
fat there's plenty of information out
there you know I'm actually supposed to
watch this documentary called
GameChanger which is a legend getting it
convinced me that that meat is bad for
me I'm gonna watch it oh I'll watch it
I'll see what I
about it I'll report back to you guys
with my complete lack of knowledge by
the way did anybody watch that stupid
[ __ ] thing about don't [ __ ] with cats
I'm so sick of those stupid ass [ __ ]
documentaries I got halfway through that
and the chick was just making it all
about herself she was so [ __ ]
annoying I just said [ __ ] this I look
the guy's name up just to see what
happened so I didn't have to watch the
rest of it that's one of my favorite
things about true crime I'm like oh wait
a minute this actually happened I don't
need to watch all of this so I just
googled the name and I just read it I
could sit there and watch ten goddamn
episodes about some [ __ ] jerk-off
that they already arrested and threw in
jail that wasn't what it was about is
about all these people was interesting
how they found all that evidence in the
room that was interesting but like the
woman you know what annoyed me was the
[ __ ] tweets the people writing like I
want to stop but I can't just everything
is about me with the [ __ ] internet
shut the [ __ ] up those stupid memes this
is me watching this nobody gives a [ __ ]
about you all right sorry acceptance
speech yeah that's what I'm worried I'm
what [ __ ] watching this amazing
musician but you know what I need to
know I need to know what you you look
like when you're [ __ ] doing that yeah
it's not about Eddie Van Halen it's
about what you and your [ __ ] [ __ ]
stamp are doing and you [ __ ] linoleum
kitchen all right acceptance speech hey
Billy McQueen Lightning McQueen what
happens when you win an award and have
to give a speech at an award show what
are you gonna say I hope you don't play
it modest oh I don't I don't know I
don't know I don't see that happening
there's a Bright's there is a bright
side to not being nominated for an award
okay the bright side is you don't have
to go to the show okay
those award shows look like a giant
[ __ ] pain in the ass I mean the
[ __ ] women the what the [ __ ] they
have to go through just vomiting up 90%
of what they ate over the last six
[ __ ] months they got to find a dress
they got to hope someone else isn't
wearing the same dress or wore it on
something else because then they get put
on that who wore it better [ __ ]
horseshit just for you to [ __ ] show
up and most likely lose and you wasted
your whole evening you could have been
at home and you [ __ ] sweatpants you
know eating a [ __ ] steak and cheese
just to join your [ __ ] life I hope I
never get nominated for anything and I'm
dead [ __ ] serious on that I don't
give a [ __ ] about any of that [ __ ] I
just want to stay home I travel too much
I spent too much time away from home as
it is I don't need another night away
from my lovely daughter
so but if I win yeah of course I'm gonna
be [ __ ] modest and I'll thank
everybody I can think of and I'll keep
it short and sweet that's it
then I'll hand back the fake trophy that
they give you and you know I'll go back
to my seat I will be a gentleman all
right
online girlfriend's dad died online
girlfriend's dad died I don't what is an
online girlfriend you guys just Skype as
you touch each yourselves is that what
it is all right dear bill I played drums
in a band a Lorien burn ah I like that I
played drums in a band DeLorean Burr
that's a great one I've been playing
MMORPGs massive multiplayer online
role-playing games I didn't want to know
what that what is that with a girl for
about three years she had a boyfriend
for the last two but he is out of the
picture you [ __ ] [ __ ] now I have
to this is gonna be part of my search
alright I'll look it up
mmm Oh RPG let's see what the [ __ ] I
love you know what I'll take the hit
here I'll look this up for the rest of
you
mmm Oh our kg let's see what our mmm Oh
part whatever massive multiplayer online
games okay just get to the what is an M
of a 13 minutes and 2 seconds for you to
tell me what the [ __ ] game is Jesus
Christ it's an online game with a large
amount of players typically from
hundreds of thousands on the same server
usually features a huge persistent open
world although the gal so this is like
[ __ ] Dungeons and Dragons for
douchebags alright I get it you're in
you're in your middle evil world and you
have to build your castle okay
online wrote what about role-playing
that seemed like was some deviant
section alright she had a boyfriend for
the last two but he's out of the picture
for the last four months we've been
sending spending almost every hour with
each other talk text FaceTime other
other than work sleep and day to day
chores is there any way I can help her
deal with her loss I'm willing to fly
from the states to Canada but I doubt
she will want to talk about the guy who
is at I thought she's gonna what she
will want to talk about the guy who was
at her dad's funeral to her family yeah
I wouldn't go up there you know I would
just say hey if you I know you're going
through obviously a really tough time if
you want to talk about it I'm here for
you if not I'll just try and make you
laugh and just try to keep it like and
let her decide and she wants to talk
about it that's what I would do but I
wouldn't I wouldn't go to see her unless
she asks you to but if you really feel
like maybe she does then I would ask her
yeah I might be
nuts am I getting a vibe would you want
me to come there this is this the first
time you ever gonna see her face to face
you're gonna show up when she her dad
dies so I gonna [ __ ] dry throat from
that uh goddamn fish head guy breathing
up all my [ __ ] oxygen
I thought they thought they breathe or
they do breathe oxygen right that their
lungs can separate the oxygen from the
water the [ __ ] does a fish lung look
like getting into showbiz is it look
like one of those [ __ ] strainers you
put powdered sugar through except you
know instead of the powdered sugar
falling through that's the it's the
oxygen yeah bill that's what it looks
like
hello Billy the Kid I'm a big fan of the
puck guys I was wondering if you can
help me figure out my future I'm a
seventeen-year-old high school kid high
school I'm seventeen year old high
school I'm a 17 year old in high school
now sir young man you've heard me try to
read the first half of that sentence
nine times okay you you're really gonna
take advice from me anyway
I am a 17 year old in high school and I
have absolutely no idea what I want to
do as a career yeah for the last few
years I've been practicing to become a
magician I've been all sorts of
magicians at my local magic shop hearing
their stories as a professional this is
making me want to become a professional
musician magician is a career so yes I
do that I don't want to sound arrogant
but I do dream of being famous on some
level and spreading joy to the world
well what the hell is wrong with that
you think I didn't do that I'm still
fantasizing about being a shirtless rock
star and that ship has clearly sailed
but I'm not a flat earther so I believe
that that ships gonna come back around
again you being a seasoned vet in show
business I was wondering if you give me
some advice on what to expect
thanks I helped you and you and your
daughter are doing well well thank you
what to expect I think you should expect
to find some good people and eventually
find a mentor that can help you out and
you're also going to probably find some
[ __ ]
bitter magicians who probably hate on
that uh that guy who does the tricks out
in the street that makes people run away
no he's not a real magician
he's [ __ ] sitting in a refrigerator
for a month you know there's always
gonna be people trying to [ __ ] on your
dream and the more successful you get
the more [ __ ] you're gonna get that's
how it works
/ they're more people that will act like
they always [ __ ] believed in you but
you know if you keep your friends some
when you were a kid and you and you you
know you remember the people that were
nice to you when you were coming up you
can have a really good gauge of who you
are when you get somewhere if that makes
any sense but I highly recommend show
business it's it's it's [ __ ] great
there's great people in it and you'll
never feel like you're working again a
day in your life unless you're doing a
guest star on a one camera shoot then
you feel like you got convicted and
where you're in the gulag in [ __ ]
Russia other than that that's it a one
camera shoot is the only thing that
sucks in show business and that's not
true there's a lot of things - - but
you're picking a great business to get
into and you know David blade that's
what I'm trying to remember you could be
the next [ __ ] David Blaine and look
at him he gets to hang out with all
these [ __ ] famous people freaking out
athletes you know so I would just say
that's what I would say be a good dude
and people will be good to you
even though there'll be a couple of
[ __ ] [ __ ] but there's a couple of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
in every business alright and you know
what the [ __ ] always end up getting
theirs and even if they don't they're
[ __ ] and they won't have real
friends so that's it
so congratulations good luck with your
magic everybody else go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on you on Thursday
once again rest in peace Kobe Bryant GG
everybody else who died it's just it's
just awful man it's just so terrible so
terrible so terrible so terrible yeah
that's it and I'm not gonna say anything
[ __ ] hacky about what you now need to
do is if I knew this [ __ ] before it
happened because I'm as stunned as you
guys are all right I'll talk to you on
Thursday